lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
reflexionar acerca de los orígenes del
álgebra los orígenes del álgebra álgebra
y las ideas que asociamos ahora
alrededor del álgebra tienen su origen
en este libro y este libro que está aquí
y viene de la traducción del título de
este libro que dice compendio de cálculo
por compresión y comparación y el autor
es un matemático que vivió en variedad y
pienso que por ahí del siglo octavo o
noveno digamos en el ochocientos veinte
de nuestra era y la palabra álgebra es
una palabra árabe que corresponde a este
título que le dio a su libro este que
vemos aquí la palabra álgebra quiere
decir recuperación y compresión
recuperación y compresión
y hace referencia en su libro a una
operación específica la de pasar cosas
de un lado a otro en una ecuación y
podemos observarlo aquí en el título
bueno la verdad yo no soy experto en
árabe ni conozco el árabe conozco de
algunos idiomas que han tomado prestados
ideas y palabras del árabe y aquí dice
alkitab y tap es libro al no casar y
aquí pienso que se refiere a contendió
frikis y quizás tanto hindi como en urdu
es cálculo al yáber y aquí está la
palabra clave aquí está la raíz de
álgebra y la asociamos con compresión sí
con compresión al kavala y ésta se
refiere a igualar o sea aquí tenemos
compresión e igualación y si quisiéramos
traducir bueno este no es un vídeo de
traducción de árabe diría algo así como
el libro el compendio de cálculos
compresión e igualación bueno este esta
es una traducción un poco burda pero es
el origen de la álgebra y este libro
pues es importantísimo y muchos lo ven
como el libro en el cual el álgebra
fue tomando sus ideas principales sus
ideas modernas la idea de ir manipulando
ecuaciones no nada más de ir resolviendo
casos por casos pero al cuaresma no fue
el primero en pensar en estas cosas y
para darnos una idea de dónde estaba
todo esto ocurriendo
él estaba en variedad y bueno pues es
esta parte que estamos mostrando aquí
del mundo en donde han ocurrido
muchísimas cosas alrededor del álgebra
voy a dibujar una línea de tiempo aquí
para que vayamos ubicando las cosas así
que esta es mi línea del tiempo y bueno
seamos religiosos o no la mayoría de los
eventos que registramos en la actualidad
están dados con respecto al nacimiento
de cristo y habrá diferentes maneras de
identificarlo dependiendo si uno
religioso o no diríamos que de este lado
está lo que llamamos de nuestra era y
desde el punto de vista religioso de
todo lo que es anterior decimos que es
antes de cristo bueno pero son
convenciones
así que más o menos por aquí estará el
año 1000 de nuestra era por la casta era
el 2000 de nuestra era y también tenemos
por aquí mil años antes de nuestra era y
2000 años antes de nuestra reina y los
primeros rastros bueno debo de aclarar
que me estoy refiriendo a que si
hiciéramos una investigación
encontraríamos muchísimos más rastros y
yo me estoy refiriendo en términos
generales y reconociendo tanta gente que
anduvo pensando en estos conceptos del
álgebra pero los registros más antiguos
de los que tenemos conocimiento se
remontan a la antigua babilonia dos mil
años antes de la era cristiana o de
nuestra era ósea y estaría más o menos
así por aquí y el registro son tablillas
de arcilla donde se observa que había
personas ya trabajando con las ideas
básicas del álgebra tal vez no usaban en
los mismos símbolos ni los mismos
números pero es claro que ya estaban
trabajando con álgebra
y otra vez esto estaba ocurriendo en la
misma parte del mundo
babilonia estaba más o menos por esta
zona del mundo en babilonia empresa en
una ciudad importantísimo un lugar muy
importante entre dos ríos y ahí es donde
están los registros que tenemos de que
la gente estaba trabajando de una manera
real con el álgebra y luego este vamos a
dar un gran brinco pero podemos decir
que las bases más importantes del
álgebra se dieron aquí dos mil años
antes de la era cristiana y luego nos
vamos a mover más o menos al año 280 de
nuestra era y entonces nos encontramos
con este griego que vivía en alejandría
si mira estamos hablando de esta parte
de grecia él vivía en alejandría cuando
era parte aún del imperio romano y
alejandría está más o menos en esta
parte del mundo y este caballero de
nombre de diofanto diofanto si no sé si
lo estoy diciendo bien pero este
caballero de nombre de diofanto que
muchas veces se les llama el padre de la
álgebra y las cosas podríamos ponerlas
un poco a debate que tanto al guarismo o
diofanto son los padres del álgebra pero
mejor digamos que cada uno tiene sus
contribuciones únicas al desarrollo del
álgebra aunque en el caso de los
historiadores occidentales pues tal vez
le den más crédito a diofanto como el
padre de la álgebra
y habrá otro grupo el cual le atribuye
al guarismo
el crédito de desarrollar el álgebra
y ahora si viajamos en el tiempo más o
menos al 580 tenemos otro personaje
central en el álgebra de nombre brama
gupta este es un matemático hindú
bueno la verdad no sé en qué parte de la
india vivía este personaje pero de una
manera burda bueno estaba en esta parte
del mundo
pero hizo grandes contribuciones a la
álgebra y obviamente un tiempo después
pues está al cual y es mi quien sentó
las bases de lo que ahora conocemos como
álgebra y con justa razón se le denomina
el padre del álgebra porque él fue el
que planteó el álgebra y desde el punto
de vista de la abstracción es mucho como
utilizamos las matemáticas actualmente
el punto de vista como trabajamos las
matemáticas en la actualidad